[Music]
fascinatingly the story of how hip-hop
happened is actually the story of how
innovation has happened in kind of every
dimension every industry you can think
of and it's this thing called cognitive
friction it's the friction between
different ideas or different ways of
doing something that actually produce a
path forward that that helps kind of any
industry become innovative I was
especially fascinated by the story of
the wu-tang clan and how they did this
in particular when they got 9 guys 9
alpha males with big egos together to
form a rap group which on the face of it
actually sounds like a terrible idea
there are different styles of rap in
this early sort of early days of hip-hop
were we're kind of all over the map you
know some were more emotional others
were more lyrical and they were all very
different and so you can just imagine
the conflict that erupts out of this and
then they got in the record studio
together and they nearly killed each
other and this was because they were
essentialist enca bleah enemies and or
at least didn't have a whole lot of
trust between them the the main guy who
got them together his name was Robert
Diggs he came up with this very clever
plan basically he said I will make a
beat I'll make a song and then everyone
has to show up and compete for the song
so you show up with your lyrics with
your rhymes and you get on the
microphone and whoever does the best job
you're on the track or you're on this
part of the track and he did this and he
basically channeled this aggressive
energy and all of these sort of
different ways of operating in hip-hop
and he got them all to instead of
fighting with each other to fight for
the record and to kind of elevate this
music and what came out of this sort of
laboratories like atom smashing together
and creating this great heat and this
great energy and out of this was born
the greatest hip hop group of all time
that many consider at that and this is
actually exactly what happened with hip
hop in general hip hop started with DJs
throwing these parties where everyone
who showed up to the party you danced on
one side
of the the dancehall or the other
depending on which music you like the
best so the DJ's would bring different
music every week to try and lure the
party to their side or the other and
this is some sort of fun party game and
what happened is when the DJ's
announcers started competing over the
best way to sort of drag people to their
side of the party suddenly that turned
into a battle or week after week the
announcers the MCS
would try and come up with more clever
things to say and it eventually turned
into this kind of war of words and music
and in fact also a war of dance and what
was awesome about it is everyone was in
it for the party for making this party
better making this event awesome and
people started bringing tape recorders
to record this music that was being
invented essentially on the spot because
it was so great and you didn't show up
to this party next week after having
lost the the lyric battle with the same
lyrics you showed up with something
different in fact all of the DJ's
started hacking their equipment so they
could do more clever things that's how
we invented fader switches and and
things that are now standard stock for
any kind of DJ or any kind of party
they also cracked open their equipment
and added more memory when they started
doing electronic music so that they
could have an edge in this battle and
you know recently jay-z was interviewed
by by David Letterman about these days
and he said that it was all about making
this experience awesome for the people
who showed up that night it wasn't about
killing the other guys even if your
lyrics were about making fun of the
other guys it was about providing a
great atmosphere and so this battle
elevated this whole thing and out of it
was born hip-hop and R&B and you know
all of the music that sort of stemmed
from that all the culture that's stemmed
from that and that's the same thing that
happened with the wu-tang clan they
cleverly channeled all of these
different kind of approaches to the
music and made something better and I
think that this is an analogy that you
can not only see in the history of
animation in science and art and
business and politics but an analogy for
what we should shoot for in our own work
for how we can get better that the
friction but the different approaches
doing battle and smashing the
if we can make sure that they don't go
too far or we turn it into something
it's about destroying someone else if we
think of it all as part of our
collaboration process to elevate our
craft then we can go much further than
we think we can on our own
[Music]